welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and the She-Hulk finale revealed
the man behind the curtain of the MCU is
actually not a man at all but an AI
robot named Kevin paradine Marvel had
Kevin feige down to the ball cap
knowledge enhanced visual
interconnectivity Nexus Jen Walters bust
out of the Disney Plus homepage into
Marvel's assembled making of documentary
suggesting this break into the fourth
wall is meant to be interpreted as her
entering our world as her breaking out
of the panels of the comics was meant to
be seen but the more you look past that
ball cap to look at the other features
of Kevin's design and the way he
functions in this world we inevitably
arrive at the question who built Kevin
whose interest does he truly serve in
this video I will prove to you that
Kevin was built and is operated by the
truly special K of the MCU Kang I mean
would you prefer the whole MCU to be the
orchestration of machine or Mayan your
mind was probably already made up before
you tapped on this video but I am
Telling You There is some compelling
evidence now you could just simply see
Kevin as meta self-satire another
algorithm operated by a studio to make
data driven programming decisions
serving the interest of investors and
viewers well not even viewers like
trunches of viewers but I'm sorry to
State the obvious but even the real
world as presented in The Shield finale
is not the real world I know I know mind
blown in our world Marvel Studios is run
by a human not by a robot and while
She-Hulk showburner Jessica GAO Cameo is
in the writer's room The Shield series
was written not by an in-person writing
staff in an office on the Disney lot but
actually written remotely in a work from
home setup so this room never existed
like this the reality that Jen Walters
wanders around on Disney's Burbank
Studio Lot is a well-crafted parody of
our real world but at the end of the day
it remains a fictional reality a reality
somewhere within the MCU Multiverse and
therefore it is not bound by the rules
and logic of our world from the moment I
finished the She-Hulk finale I couldn't
help but feel a parallel between this
and the finale of Loki both episodes and
their Seasons with mind-blowing meta
reveals that everything in the heroes
world was re-scripted by a mysterious
all-knowing weirdo hidden away in a
fortune is that the hero must fight
their way into and then engage this
Wizard of Oz figure not with their fists
but an intellectual debate based on the
extent of the hero's Free Will and
despite an apparent Victory the hero
ends the episode reacting in bafflement
upon seeing the master planner's wishes
carried out anyway and while she-hulk's
finale takes her down quite a rabbit
hole into this hell based on the real
world of the viewer the Loki finale did
pull a similar meta move if you remember
it opened on a Marvel Studios title card
that echoed with famous quotes from Real
World History in real world music as we
ascended up from one black hole and then
back down another black hole just like
She-Hulk comes from one meta portal and
goes down into another meta portal now
the key difference is that while Loki's
villain he remains was a human who used
an artificial facade robotic time
Keepers and whatever the helmet's
minutes was Kevin is essentially the
inverse what Jen thinks will be a human
but is actually an artificial
intelligence using a human facade but
despite the artificiality of Kevin there
are a lot of interesting things going on
with his design we mentioned the
signature Kevin feige ball cap he has
red green blue lights like the red green
blue base colors and pixels of digital
screens he's attached by an appendage
that lowers from the ceiling like he's a
trapped prisoner in this Vault and on
his back are two revolving wheels that
look like the reels of a film projector
overall this guy is beat up and
motorized like this Tech is a bit dated
and on his side is a display screen that
reads quality analysis success analysis
micro CPU board status stabilizer Arm
Control and listings for box office
Marvel and midnight referring to opening
night box office numbers but it's not so
much what these things are saying it's
how they are displaying them the black
screen in digital text is the same
typeface as every computer screen we see
in the TVA in Loki the training test
that Loki takes at the top of episode 2
the time bomb locations and dates that
rensslayer sees at the end of episode 2
and every Nexus point location and date
that Scrolls across the ticker the only
difference is that the TVA text is
orange colored this text is white but
otherwise it is the same black
background and the same blocky font also
worth noting how Kevin functions and how
similar it is to what the TVA
essentially does now visual effects are
getting so good that you can practically
smell what you're watching but if you'd
like to smell something more appealing
than a sweaty superhero suit scentbirds
got you covered scentbird is reimagining
everything about how people discover
shop for purchase and even experience
fragrances sin bird is a great place to
begin or deepen your relationship with
fragrances Sanford lets you choose a new
designer fragrance to try every month
just for 17 and every month you get to
pick what you'd want to receive so there
are no surprises they have perfumes and
colognes and a lot of unisex options
with each fragrance you'll get a 30 day
supply so you can try out fragrances
before committing to a full-size bottle
a bottle that could cost you over 150
and some are even 300 to 500 scentbird
carries Brands like Prada Gucci Versace
as well as Indie labels like Skylar
heretic and confessions of Rebel senford
believes that your fragrance is an
opportunity to express your
individuality and their wide selection
gives each and every person the power to
express themselves through fragrance
this month I got Brit for men by
Burberry the one for men from Dolce
Gabbana and the Dylan blue poor Homme
from Versace so let's try this Dylan
blue fragrance oh
oh man oh man is this what being a
grown-up smells like I'm so scared but
also so excited so exhilarated why is my
voice so deep no for real though this
Dylan blue fragrance is awesome and the
card gives you the scent profile hits
you with a bit of grapefruit and
Bergamot but then it like settles you
down to a warm bed of black pepper and
Patchouli it makes me feel dare I say
Debonair if you're in the U.S or Canada
you can get started on finding your
fragrance with scentbird for just a
little over seven dollars for your first
month click the link in the description
below and use the coupon code nr3 for 55
off Kevin uses an algorithm to write all
MCU storylines the TDA does the same
thing from a script written by he who
remains and we see this with every
iconic shot in the MCU suggested to be
storyboarded by Kevin evidenced by that
highlight reel that Jen sees as she
walks into the Vault however let's not
forget that the TVA has the same exact
footage in episode 1 Mobius uses a film
projector to show Loki what his life
would have been in the 616 MCU history
we see footage from the 2012 Avengers
from Thor the Dark World Thor Ragnarok
and Avengers Infinity War but this
history was not shown from any like
objective God's eye view of it or from
the point of view of the Loki himself
but using the same exact camera angles
stay exact editing as the choices of the
filmmakers who made those movies Joss
Whedon Alan Taylor taekwatiti and the
Russo brothers so TBA archive footage is
the same literal footage that Kevin
designs Kevin also edits plotlines with
the Precision that the TVA prunes Nexus
branches out of existence what can we
not do Todd gets Hulk powers like the
powers aren't the villain he is erasing
blood plot what is erasing Todd's
hulkblood subplot if not pruning it from
she-hulk's timeline there's also this
idea of using robots at all he who
remains ran the TVA using AI robots just
like this the timekeepers were robotic
puppets and then there was that robot
that declosed Loki in episode 1 like
Kevin that robot was suspended with
loose wires had chipped paint and these
thin clasping arms then of course is
what Kevin stands for knowledge enhanced
visual interconnectivity Nexus Nexus as
in Nexus points even in his name is the
same internal company language coined by
he who remains for the TVA lastly there
are Kevin's eyepieces the red green and
blue lights are not cameras or
photoreceptors they are lights that
project light outward they actually
remind me of the projectors on the Stark
drones which can project any
three-dimensional object so what are
these things projecting or designed to
project I mean really the possibilities
are endless
yes Miss minutes a mysteriously
disembodied sentient AI who occupies
physical space but with no visible light
source projecting her into that space we
still don't really have answers to what
Miss minutes is only that she's an asset
controlled by he remains an unofficial
mis-minute Twitter account tweeted
Kevin's a good friend of mine again it's
unofficial but the writer of Loki and
Multiverse Madness and Secret Wars
Michael Waldron follows this account so
I don't know but at the end of the day
it would not surprise me if Miss minutes
and Kevin were connected because there's
only room for one in Universe Master
clock maker in the MCU and we can choose
to view Kevin as nothing more than a
meta bit of satire to heighten she hopes
break into the fourth wall but robots
are built by people I choose to live in
a world with human accountability with
ghosts in the machine and with deus's in
the day of six machines for every Ultron
there's a Tony Stark for every Zola
algorithm there's a Zola and I think for
every Kevin there is a Kang a Kang who
scripted every word of Jen Walters
fourth wall breaking and scripted a path
for her to break into a real world that
was actually a pocket reality of his
design two like drawing Neo into the
screenwold room of the architect give
the hero the illusion of choice but keep
them on the path that you already laid
out for them anyway let me know what you
think of this Theory and you can follow
me on Tick Tock Instagram and Twitter at
avos follow new rockstars And subscribe
to new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love and thanks again to
scentbird for sponsoring this video and
be sure to check out the links below
thanks for watching bye
[Music]